Bisher galten Quantencomputer als extrem ungenau.
Für bestimmte Berechnungen können sie einfach
nicht verwendet werden, weil ihr Fehlerquote
zum Teil bei fast 70% liegt.
Jetzt hat aber ein Forschungsteam der Eidgenössischen
Technischen Hochschule (ETH) Zürich ein Verfahren
entwickelt, um diese Fehleranfälligkeit dramatisch
zu reduzieren.
Wir jetzt eine neue Ära des Quantencomputings
erreicht?
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Bei einem Wettkampf der Quantencomputer 2017,
war die Fehlerquote reisig.
Der Vorläufer des kommerziellen IBM-Quantenrechners
Q-System trat gegen einen Quantencomputer
der University of Maryland an.
Der IBM-Rechner war teilweise bis zu 1000
mal schneller als sein Konkurrent, dieser
hatte jedoch eine eine höhere Zuverlässigkeit.
Er kam auf einen Wert von 77 bis 90 Prozent,
während der IBM-Rechner nur auf 35 bis 74
Prozent kam, also deutlich mehr Fehler machte.
Das ist immer noch das Hauptproblem von Quantencomputern.
Sie sind zwar unglaublich schnell, aber machen
eben Fehler.
Aber sie sind die Computer, die in Zukunft
wahnsinnig komplexe Modelle durchrechnen können.
Zum Beispiel den Brexit mit allen möglichen
Folgen für Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft.
Normale Computer scheitern heute noch an solchen
Aufgaben.
Quantencomputer haben überhaupt die Möglichkeit
bei Rechenaufgaben mit so vielen unbekannten
eine Menge möglicher Szenarien zu bestimmen.
IBM rechnet mit Fortschritten bei vielen komplexen
Problemen: Medikamentenforschung, Berechnungen
in der Logistik, Finanzwirtschaft, Künstliche
Intelligenz, Datensicherheit.
Alles Felder, wo wir mit der heutigen Computertechnologie
an Grenzen stoßen.
Aber wie könnten die Fehler von Quantencomputern
eingeschränkt werden?
Ein Forschungsteam um den Physiker Jonathan
Homme hat dafür ein revolutionäres Verfahren
entwickelt.
Dafür versetzten sie die Q-Bits eine Quantencomputers
in ganz bestimmte Schwingungen.
Ein Q-Bit, ist das Bit in einem Quantencomputer,
also wie die null und eins in unseren herkömmlichen
Computern.
Im Prinzip also das gleiche, nur dass ein
Q-Byte, also acht verbundene Q-Bits nicht
nur einen Wert, sondern alle Werte gleichzeitig
enthalten kann, also quasi schonmal nur dadurch
256mal so schnell wie ein normaler Computer
ist.
Allerdings gibt es beim Auslesen der Informationen
immer wieder Fehler, weil Quantenzustände
beschrieben durch die Heisenbergsche Unschärferelation
Zustände mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit annehmen
und diese Zustände können durch äußere
Einflüsse verändert werden.
Teilchen sind ja nicht nur Teilchen, sondern
auch Wellen, wie wir es bei Licht ja ganz
deutlich erleben.
Und den Schweizer Forschern ist jetzt gelungen
diese Wellenfunktion der Teilchen so zu beeinflussen,
dass sie nicht mehr wie weiche Wellen aussehen,
sondern wie die Zinken eines Kamms.
Jetzt sind die Teilchen plötzlich gar nicht
mehr so unscharf, sondern die Messunsicherheiten
finden jetzt nur noch an den ganz schmalen
Zinken dieses Kammes statt.
Störungen sind jetzt viel leichter zu sehen:
Christa Flühmann aus dem Forschungsteam:
"Unsere Realisierung dieser periodischen oder
kammartigen Schwingungszustände des Ions
stellt einen wichtigen Schritt in Richtung
einer solchen eventuellen Fehlerbestimmung
dar".
Jetzt will das Forschungsteam Verfahren entwickeln,
um die Störungen aufzuspüren und dann herauszurechnen.
Bei einem nächsten Wettkampf zwischen Quantencomputern,
könnte also die Fehlerquote schon bald stark
sinken.
Quantencomputer, unbedingt draufklicken.
Ein Megavideo mit der Erklärung des Quantencomputers.
Also Draufklicken, anschauen und abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!